hello friends I'm Ilana and today I am
playing Ghost Recon wildlands to
celebrate the upcoming beta of Ghost
Recon a breakpoint thanks to AMD and
Ubisoft of course I'll be telling you
guys how you can get free keys to check
out the beta yourself somewhere in the
middle of this video so stay tuned but
for everyone who is asked when I play on
when I'm playing on PC you can check out
my room to a video but otherwise I'm
playing on an AMD powered system on a
rise in seven CPU with a Radeon 7
graphics card hello let me see your your
wonderful character you created a well I
didn't put that much time into it but I
think I'm hot so oh I haven't I passed
you know what oh I've been here for one
second ok you get in the back you get
the bench come on ok I'll get the check
now you can get in the trunk
alright take us somewhere exciting all
right well we drop the boys I'm gonna
convoy incoming shoot this guy to the
driver Tina
it's not as thriving it's just so
detailed look at it sees me say I would
like to ask you some questions he is a
cowboy
what kind of cowboy drives a call that
looks like this though should we kill
him
all right good job we got the
information
[Music]
Oh convoys here yeah oh oh that's very
concerning
okay this hasn't gone great okay oh he's
right there oh yeah I got him Jesus did
you just fall down having a nap I think
that you you like you're kind of between
my legs right now
oh I felt violated whew my character is
a captain Canada nomad cyborg Canada I'm
kind of Kent can come Android uh-huh all
right get in the truck she's getting
used to get in the truck good that's
good that's quick thinking a woman
should know her place who wants to fly
we're not really cooked
there's no chunking oh it's uh it's like
The Twilight Zone movie all over again I
don't feel comfortable with the way of
driving this at all but look at these
moves give me you got the seating we're
gonna crash all right
Oh way to set up some parachutes
come--we should it be smoking like this
I don't know do we
there's a man sell some [ __ ] copy quick
we got civilians you are in the way
tonight this is the plan we're gonna do
this tactically y'all ready for some
spice well I don't I don't have many the
worst it's a fact there's like two men
they actually haven't noticed us
so I haven't despite how hey we have two
helicopters or now okay my parachute now
please
yeah I don't think this one's gonna be
working anytime soon
this is a cop helicopter it is you need
add yeah it's got a horn on it I know
isn't it cool it's got like a bayonet
imagine we could do with that we're
gonna Pierce of birds so many activities
okay I have the option to locate skill
points locate rebel ops alarm is brown
and scalp all anyways which one fit I
lied to you we're late now son yeah I'm
gonna stay in the air weren't you guys
haven't spotted I'm just gonna show all
of that yeah once we've been spotted
we're gonna perfectly execute this in
stealth yeah okay press three to use
your handguns and then everyone hit ctrl
and then although that's a good start my
handgun let's do it
please don't hit me
please don't hit me with your vehicle
sir please now stop dammit
okay why did you stop so late that was
very dangerous
that was a mistake stop time you threw a
grenade all right never mind
well we almost stopped that one guy
still failed but we got close oh they're
a lot of them I just gotta go to
suppress my breath that's what I got
it's a good time they're all coming for
you Potts
oh that's fine all right in front of you
yeah that's fine I'm just in some rocks
I feel safe in the rocks okay
rocks protects me okay I have a point de
vente oh they are all coming for me oh
they're all coming for me oh please
someone do something oh god oh no oh god
oh god oh god no all right didn't work
oh my god they witness my kill why do I
ever play video games no this is my
fault don't do something I'm hoping it
worst we got him let's get in this plane
point I'm hell yes plane adventures
gonna go I'm actually nervous about this
now the fact that you didn't know how to
take off in the plane has concerned me a
bit and it's so I all I need to know how
to do is take off and land flying is
very rickety oh boy
know what fine everyone's fine how we
get over all this well where are you
gonna land moving around I'm livin
around where did the smoke come from is
that always there and yeah that's just
the air that's how that looks
got it earth in the air before
chemtrails yeah okay yeah this looks
friendly okay tuck and roll when we land
here we go baby
okay Pamela all right yeah it was pretty
good
sorry who are you guys get out I want
all right now wait ah not really not
what just happened to me it's my plane
I believe you're hit by a helicopter Oh
that'll get you
oh oh oh that's the thing you just did
well I don't feel great about it
the planes still walking it's all his
fault that's good
Ilana do you have frag grenades on you
does this person have grenades I don't
think so
oh no I have one huh I haven't once
never good okay can you make sure that
nobody takes this plane from us ever
again okay yeah cool good job is that
what he won were you telling me to frag
grenades that the plan yes that's
absolutely what I was telling you this
rebounded oh wait how does this thing
fly
that's know it that's close enough it's
complicated isn't it I don't think
that's gonna make it very long
that's a saya I went back away back away
yeah all right okay I can tag them with
my dryer best okay yeah no hablo English
are we so stealthy no we're pretty pass
stuff I just lit up a truck full of
civilians by accident so steli efti won
it I've got the guy all right all right
Terry get him oh yeah he's doing like
little eyebrow raises yeah no you
flooding with me it's already ready time
we going gumballs are very end in here
oh okay okay oh whoa you guys really
went off-road huh real quick whoo baby
okay love it
well yeah we can't go on the road it's a
stealth well that's two down all right
no but I'll stop crime has gone great we
go I am also stuck a lot of yeah do you
reckon you guys can can make it to my
truck somehow or what I'm dead you're
dead he's bleeding out I feel like we
just go I'll save you
couple man's fifty man's easy now I
killed a pillow accidentally you that
was absolutely might be might be almost
instantaneous inton looking at the
enemies yet shot a man I killed
that's fine there's casualties they
would have died anyway if we were right
Nets
okay there's a plane right below us no
we do like those I could get that no
problem no problem
all right I'll be back oh okay that's
not a plane that's two boat icons they
kind of look like a plane I will be
voting in momentarily just doing over
there you swapping seats I am some kind
of cool dance I need to poop just hang
out right out of the photo copy all
right this is the part where you get
free stuff so if you guys want to check
out the Ghost Recon break point beta
which takes place from September 5th to
8th AMD is giving out free beta keys on
September 4th it's on a limited
first-come first-served basis for those
who register on AMD's website I will
leave a link in the description below
for that one you can get the first four
hours of PvE participate in 4v4 PvP
death matches explore three of the
diverse zones on the map and take on new
missions which will be added daily if
you want to guarantee access to the beta
rather than having some of you win by
commenting below or signing up by AMD if
you preorder the game you'll be able to
do so I'll leave a link in the
description below for how you guys can
do that but I will also be picking some
of my viewers to win codes so just tell
me what the best part of this video is
because this video is full of a lot of
very silly quotes reach out and get you
some codes so yeah thank you guys for
watching
I'm a little bit worried you come in a
bit hot here dogs not your fix this it's
okay it's okay in a plane how do you
want to get it I'll talk about right now
how do I switch to driver's seat when
you jump out all right still going real
quick I don't know good luck all right
good soft landing in the dirt yeah ha Oh
beautiful
what good just breathe that is one sexy
pilot all right Sophia my gun out oh no
you have a mu got that sniper sniper
yeah send it setting and sending a drone
I missed excellent I missed again
excellent there immediately allotted to
us self though they're just wearing Lee
persona where self failed again
immediately they're just they're scared
they just don't know what they're scared
of that's how they stall for at all
ready yeah we don't want to talk about
it awesome copter oh no all right let's
go shoot shoot the pilot hang on let me
see if I can get this crossbow out yet
but fixing you get him uh there we go
excuse me so it's crossing the road oh
that's going down spinning wildly come
on take him out carefully yeah we're not
great at this huh
all right new plan new plan alright
listen hear me up okay we don't even try
and Yelp can you lay this hahaha
the new plan is we get one also don't we
also don't go hard we just Sprinter
while stealth art with stealth walk in
just get in it believe that come try it
okay I see it you're in a car I shot it
with one bullet exploded so how do I die
Oh a little bit nervous right now
hey what Cyril saw for me and I'm quite
weak but my crossbow is very cool all
right I won't wait no wait
you guys are really stepping on this
crossbow I promise can I get on this
this nice helicopter uh yeah we know we
should do miss remar know why hashtag
has interplay is that hashtag free
tomorrow I agree
oh my god we're doing a flip I'm really
back it out that got out of hand very
false weave why why are we settling why
do we suddenly care about Amaru
previously I thought look at this was
that he was in s trade oh but you cooked
we're gonna take with planet pizza truck
it's green and gold those are the calls
of us to hang on I'm sorry I had the
audacity to get the seat next to you how
do you coach Siot going to get in the
mood get in the truck I caught it
there's no trunk of this car that's so
sad oh I'm so sorry you know that I
understand if you want to shower after
this we'll see this rise oh boy
free Maru a buyer's gonna tell us where
to find a new helicopter to steal if he
doesn't um but you Tim we don't need
that many more columns what do we need
like fit I know if I don't get three
thousand coms out of them are really
rolling in the hot on the Maru here huh
all right
bar is gonna be saved oh hey okay
whatever with dollars
damn it clean no [ __ ] no ok what's still
good what's still good we're not gonna
morrow maybe alright to be clear our
goal is to get borrow wherever we're
going alive
all right now it's so you should have
enough cops I have enough comms for a
parachute I don't know I don't know I
think Amara I do good just leaving with
the house I bought my parachute all
right we all even all right let's do
they see Hey he's guys he's looking at
me funny he's really looking at me I
will prove my pilot he don't staring at
me he's not doing great
this isn't appropriate also he's really
trusting I've just hanging outside there
yeah
he doesn't know how many of these we've
crashed clearly I have no idea
we are infamous yep all the local
newspapers but thank God he's a literate
I have to sit through a cutscene now oh
well Mario keeps complaining about her
he is and now he's bleeding out now our
situation I see okay
Wow that is how baby how did he die do
you know like my landing this is
beautiful Doug you made all it we did it
all right what's the plan plan get on
bikes do dope style on bites dude up
stuff all right Tom buck I'm ready I'm
ready I'm ready
yeah my stunt fail didn't go well I got
down the stunt was not a success how do
you really are you playing a mouse
keyboard I got control I ran over a
civilian but I we lead open them so it
was cool I think they would have
depressed they were alive to remember it
your honor
damn she really deserves if Jennifer was
alive to tell you she would say I looked
dope as [ __ ] oh hey hey oh that oh that
was me
oh boy that we got you I'm sorry I
didn't mean to run you over we thought
what you were civilian yeah we gotta
find a chopper seven all right I see one
down here let's go down here locate the
wardens computer it is is it because the
wood was a social media or something I
think yes what they said go go yeah
let's fly it over - yeah we're gonna get
out the wardens a Twitter account and
take out some very controversial plan
I'll just a up here and provide air
support really when you guys get spotted
not quite on board a dude controls this
is full stealth
I've done the first four missions this
game like 20 times
we should be able to sell through this
all right we have alerted the enemy
[Laughter]
Oh yo down yeah what happened to you I'm
coming for you I got I went too hard as
playing power by Kanye West then maybe
he'll tell her that I was no one man
should have all that power we're going
in all units commence assault I match
I'm down this mountain like a goat okay
so we just running around busy for a
laptops right there to find some kind of
computer just imagine you're an
influencer yeah where is my [ __ ]
MacBook where would I be
what of graffiti painted in bed know
someone of my chat said it's inside
second-level top of the hill where you
high I told you I found it it was in
this but it wasn't below I was like the
warden he's gonna be up top right come
on roll the back roll back it ain't easy
I don't think that ever happened thank
God we weren't recording it did happen
no I don't think that the warden
overlooks the prison I didn't hear that
good luck
huh should not have not just wait what
happened oh look at my no wait wait all
right jumping oh sure you have
you paid for it with your life just my
head just smashed into the side of the
what the mountain it wasn't great it
wasn't my fighters oh cool alright
alright keep on pushing wish we had a
helicopter that would be someone say
helicopter an armadillo really yeah we
just chased them around come here you
little scamp life please don't shoot my
armadillo oh my god oh my god oh my god
could have alarmed the enemies I did you
a favor I'm a dill oh yes that was
pretty scenic you sang this armadillo
kind of alarm the enemies while your
crashed helicopter exploded behind you I
didn't crash crash is alive for me huh
where is he on your screen oh he's quick
he's a speedy little guy oh there is
speedy little fella my armadillo died
the sirens already going off we haven't
even entered the area yet and the sirens
go nope don't do that don't do that at
all stay get out of the car dad okay
we're not doing that no no no I feel
like I haven't been spotted I'm doing I
have freed some rebels they instantly
grabbed a bunch of guns and started
shooting everyone excellent
love it alright well it's good to know
it's not just us thing
five that lad okay unidad so me I
thought that was only one but they were
too so now I am engaged
oh can I get you guys to the deck babe
not today [ __ ]
- oh that's part of a helicopter we
might have done that I'm not sure oh
yeah that was absolutely me i'ma tell
okay there it is oh we got a truck I
went around what's up oh this is nice
this is undamaged right oh wait what
this is looks like there's nobody in the
driver's seat I will do my best to keep
it on man this charge of driven by a
ghost no well yeah that's no no I'm
driving that's how new it is duper nice
I'm concerned we'll go right past a
helicopter helicopter yeah helicopter I
hardly know her I lost way too hot I bet
he didn't deserve bigger right right
here you're right it's not driving cars
still some kinks or no should we be
worried about the smoke or is that show
nuts that's normal that's news the pop
stars are working at full speed I see oh
that's not good ID still want to get in
oh no
ah back to the van wait wait is it
really completely broken yep it's
completely broken I can't